on semblait si mes envies de claire
agile regardez là il avait sorti le
grand jeu en montrant ses talents de
magicien les yeux ébahis de damien
canivet zh alors damiens vous allez voir
c'est un peu le complice au bonneteau
qui essaient appâter le pigeon vous
allez voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
débattez la douche
[Applaudissements]
pour la rapide aux parts de marché un
petit tour à tout le public non avec il
va faire disparition sa passion elle
elle est folle de vous sans rigoler elle
vous vont démontrer puisque c'est le mot
nation qu'il adore ça et qu'il est très
fort mais comment tu sais tout ça toi a
laissé des tours n'avait pas compris qui
passe je vous le dis que la pub se
termine elle va aller retrouver maxime
comme s'il venait la chercher à la
sortie de nuit c'est vous savez vous pas
l'installer avant même temps pour se
maquiller je sais pas si c'est très
intelligent de faire disparaître les
bagues la mairie repas est évidemment
21h20 vous devez pas être coaché ouais
alors c'est compliqué un crayon va
essayer de l'amener d'accord je vois pas
de concentration évidemment
allez petit tour de quelques bureaux
[Rires]
tombée de la nuit des musées où il il
est où le stylo il est en tout cas
rapide un petit truc à des trucs rapide
ouais il est là le silo
[Rires]
il
j'adore ça lui plaît cela dort à la
belle qui va essayer moi cette année
spreads à fait d'accord t'as bien là
dessus telus est non
ouais frère non mais tu publies tes
complices écran facial et des fermes et
saint gobain complice et ses biens a
vraiment disparates mais aujourd'hui
c'est bien une idée mais le bal des
réponses sur leur travail en avant la
fin de la chronique de jean luc l'heure
d'aller saluer les bons boutons week-end
alors oui vous avez joué les
téléspectateurs également vous allez
placer vos deux mains de la même manière
que moi tout le monde va léser très bien
les issues de secours se trouve alors à
présent vous a laissée aux portes à
présent vous allez les tournées à
l'intérieur comme ça comme ça très bien
à présent vous allez les accrocher de
cette manière
et toc
et là vous serrez d'un fort bien fort
bien fort de public les téléspectateurs
également devenir fort bien voire même
sort gâtés à troyes où vas tu vas y que
moi wen et bien aller 2-3 cas et vous
replacez chien est mort naturellement je
crois que j'apprenne moindre
[Applaudissements]